let's go next to our caller from the 385
area code call her from 385 who's there
David hey who's this hi this is Alex and
I just wanted to mention that I saw a
previous video you did on the on the
carbon tax and you talked about that and
at the end of the video you asked why
not do this carbon tax proposal and I
just I think that's a important question
to ask the people of France right now
these yellow vests protesting do you
think their grievances are legitimate or
should they just suck it up and buy a
Tesla I mean I think that it's sort of a
false choice right to say the two
options are the grievances over which
people are violently protesting and
setting things on fire are legitimate or
they're not and thus they should suck it
up and buy a Tesla I mean listen number
one there's a distinction between carbon
taxes at the industrial level and
gasoline taxes would you grant that no
they passed the taxes on to the consumer
okay but so that's something that can be
done but what I'm saying to you is that
it's conceivably possible that you can
target carbon taxes in a way that is not
going to be disproportionately and sort
of regressively impacting people at the
pump like that's conceivable right no
it's not okay because we we are the ones
that consume the product we're the ones
that are using the carbon
yes but the gas taxes would not
necessarily the price of gas would not
necessarily be impacted if you do
targeted targeted carbon taxes for
companies that are manufacturing in a
particularly dirty industry for example
like you can separate the flow that
economic flow from the driving of
vehicles and gas tax I don't think you
can that that's I mean that's kind of
you're thinking you're assuming that
these carbon companies are these
energy companies have you know these
these deep pockets and we're just gonna
take the money from them and that's
gonna save the planet no I mean I think
that's a sort of caricature of the view
let's see maybe so I don't know if we're
gonna agree on that part so I guess your
question your initial question was
should the protesters have legitimate
concerns or should they buy a Tesla I
think they have legitimate concerns and
my advice is not for them to go and buy
Tesla's I mean listen we get gas in
France is extraordinarily more expensive
than in the United States so I think
that you know France needs to figure out
what they need to do in the United
States where we're doing the opposite
where we're so heavily subsidizing
gasoline such that there's very little
incentive for the development of
high-speed rail you've got both the auto
and airline industry's lobbying against
high-speed rail because hey in the end
gas is cheap in the United States the
situation is just drastically different
and we know that in the u.s. we are so
off from equilibrium when it comes to
gas prices that I think that in the net
we would benefit from more expensive gas
although I would be extraordinarily
concerned that it would hit the people
who can least afford to pay more for gas
so I completely acknowledge that right
so I mean but that's the idea of the of
the tax is trying to get people to
change their behavior on use energy and
to get them to try and transition to
these more expensive green alternatives
I reject the idea that in the long term
these are going to be objectively more
expensive alternatives when you account
for number one being like hold on hold
on a second hold on a second when you
account for the fact that right now we
subsidize polluting types of fuels when
you account over the net no there's no
such thing as non polluting types of -
all right I'm trying to have a
conversation with you but you're just
not allowing me to and I am out of time
so I'm gonna let you go I I do
appreciate the call but I would love to
be able to have more of a conversation
with you I'm sorry that we weren't able
to
to everybody there are people who are
still holding and we are done for today
but we will take calls again that I
promise you thanks to everybody who
called in